[MUSIC PLAY]
JONATHAN MCNULTY: Trulia's mission
is to make it as easy as possible
for you to find the home of your dreams.
Trulia works with MLS across the United States
to bring in an incredible amount of data for available properties.
LAUREN HIRASHIMA: Trulia's purpose, in fact,
is to assist you in your search for a home.
JONATHAN MCNULTY: So far, Trulia has done incredibly well.
In fact, we see more than half of our business now
on mobile applications.
So when we think of products in the future,
when we think about how we can serve our users,
which is really more than anything else
mobile applications are all
what we do very much on mobile devices.
Android gives us a lot of flexibility
to embed new and creative features for our users.
LAUREN HIRASHIMA: Android has it for us
made it possible to create a much more stable program
and also to be able to repeat much faster.
Innovation is at the heart of Trulia's being.
And we love innovation as the core of Google
being.
JONATHAN MCNULTY: We have every quarter
a week dedicated to engineering product design
To really focus on what they think is important.
We saw our forwarding notification system.
We've seen our mobile apps.
We've seen many of the programs that you live today
on the site, from our innovation weeks.
LAUREN HIRASHIMA: After submitting the forwarding notifications
turned on Android,
we have seen an immediate impact.
We learned and did it
and then saw a 30% increase in involvement.
And Android engagement is twice as high
as on our other platforms.
We initially saw a number of complaints
when we sent too many notifications.
Therefore, we quickly responded and realized
that there is an ideal target for the number of notifications
what you need to send to your users one day.
JONATHAN MCNULTY: We recently launched notices for nearby homes.
It actually uses a wall-mounted technology
with which Google empowered us.
LAUREN HIRASHIMA: Just say you walk with your dog
and you're close to a new listing.
Then you will receive an alert.
You can just get the alert on your watch,
see high-level details about the property,
roles through a few photos and the agent call or email
send directly to the agent from your watch.
It was very easy to develop for Android Wear.
It took an engineer a few weeks
to have our program live on Google Play.
We see more action coming from our Android platform
off any other platform.
We partnered with Google
regarding these new products and new platforms
and value both companies.